once upon a time Johnny Depp was the
most intriguing actor in Hollywood now
one hit franchise will usher in the end
of his creative choices turning him into
a boring parody of himself but who cares
now he owns a [ __ ] Island Pirates of
the Caribbean witness the Disney
vacation of pirates history's most
notorious foul-mouthed rapists and
murderers where the cursing is PG
pestilent traitorous cow hearted yeasty
codpiece
ruthless soulless cross-grained rate
becomes raid raid pillage plunder and
otherwise pilfer my Weasley blackouts
and murder is physically impossible
miss no nut dick no buckle your squashes
for curse of the Black Pearl a
straightforward adventure romp that
everyone loved then Dead Man's Chest
that everyone was sort of on board for
where they all betray each other to find
a teleporting squid monsters hard at
World's End that everyone was totally
fed up with where they all betray other
while the squid monster teams up with
the British East India Company causing
the pirate un to release a sea goddess
who's in love with the squid monster
except for when she isn't and on
Stranger Tides that v wait what they
made a fourth one ah how many of these
things can they do they're based on pink
theme park ride for God's sake Johnny
Depp shines as Jack Sparrow Captain Jack
Sparrow
the legendary pirate made out of
dreadlocks and guyliner
watch this oscar-worthy match between
actor and role as he hams it up with a
trademark barrage of catchphrases I'm
Captain Jack Sparrow seven seven seven
seven seven seven seven seven seven
seven savvy impractical escapes
and Silly Walks
in this half-drunk Keith Richards
impression that really should be dead by
now
kind of like Keith Richards this is face
look like a spin to the Fountain of
Youth spend the rest of your time in the
pale embrace of the boring lovers
orlando bloom and keira knightley two
perfect faces in the middle of a scurvy
ridden hellhole whose will they won't
they relationship will have everyone
saying where did Jack Sparrow go until
they're replaced in the fourth one by
they're cheaper but just as pale
equivalence batten down the hatches for
nearly ten overstuffed maritime hours of
impossible sword fights
stupid wigs
terrible tea alcoholism why is the rain
gone why is the rum always gone rums
can't hide the rum that song from the
ride
drink of me hearties yo ho oh and women
dressed in cinemas least convincing boy
disguises moustache or not Oh totally
pork that dude
starring Captain Jack Sparrow's from any
more of these movies Keira daily
barnacle bill y not zoidberg finicky
Deadwood men tell no tales
Captain Morgan Miss Cleo a Japanese porn
star and Orlando Florida Jack Sparrow of
the Caribbean and some other pirates
used to be cool man what the hell
happened to you close your eyes and
pretend it's all a bad dream it's how I
get by be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers
hey screen junkies do you love movies as
much as we do then check out movies on
break where you can watch tons of
full-length movies for free on break.com
or any of breaks free mobile apps click
the link in the description below to
start watching and tell them screen
junkie sent you why is the rum always
gone you can catch flies with honey
which you catch more honey's being fly
Ronnie James Dio chubby wuzzle nuzzles
are the pickle bring me everyone
everyone